in uber has turned to the Middle East
for its biggest investment ever the
company announcing a three and half
billion dollar raise from Saudi Arabia's
private in a public investment fund it's
part of obras most recent funding round
and keeps the valuation at sixty two and
a half billion only that's right sixty
two and a half billion Saudi wealth fund
managing director will also take a seat
on the board as part of the deal
Bloomberg News startups reporter Erik
newcomer joins us from the newsroom with
more Erik this is shocking are these
guys on like a perma fundraising scheme
here they keep raising money and keep
raising money and keep raising money
it's crazy it yeah it certainly feels
like that I their balance sheet now is
eleven billion nine and a half billion
of it in cash that's cash on hand so
they are flush with money and all from
the private markets you know they just
you know raising from everybody Under
the Sun they've now raised from what
Google TPG benchmark and now all you
know these huge sovereign wealth funds
so everybody you can imagine is invest
in uber it seems there's a million
curious asbestos one is it the the
valuation well I'm just gonna call it
obscenely high the devaluation stays at
that level even though it's a subsequent
round how does that work I mean whose
equity about selling at that point yeah
my miners say is you know they'd filed
to raise 2.1 billion and they they
extended the round so they they'd they
were gonna raise 2.1 at sixty two point
five and then they said okay i guess we
can get a bunch more money and they keep
the same valuation so i think you're
right to pay attention to that i don't
think it's a bad sign but it sure
certainly shows that they're probably
reaching a ceiling when it comes to what
people will pay to invest nuba right now
yeah I would say the sixty-two billion
dollar valuation is not a bad sign for a
company that deep has we presume no
profits right yeah yeah that is that is
an expensive company a expensive
valuation for any for any company and
yeah that certainly certainly not
profitable trying to be profitable in
the United States but competing
aggressively with lift so that situation
is and the fact which comes from Saudi
Arabia suggests some global ambitions of
which
we'll certainly keep an eye for Eric
newcomer Thank You Barnes a huge story
and we're glad to have you on to talk
about it